THROUGH ALL THAT LIKE SO MANY
OTHERS.
>> GOOD TO BE BACK, THANKS,
SEAN.
>> Sean: JOE DELIVERED A
SPEECH ABOUT BUILDING BRIDGES
AFTER THE SPEECH HE GAVE EARLIER
IN THE WEEK, COMPARING HIS
POLITICAL OPPONENTS TO BULL
CONNOR, GEORGE WALLACE,
JEFFERSON DAVIS WHILE ALSO
REFERRING TO TENS OF MILLIONS OF
AMERICANS AS DOMESTIC ENEMIES --
WOW.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> I KNOW WHAT I STAND.
I WILL NOT YIELD, I WILL NOT
FLINCH, I WILL DEFEND THE RIGHT
TO VOTE.
OUR DEMOCRACY AGAINST ALL
ENEMIES, FOREIGN, AND YES
DOMESTIC.
I ASK EVERY ELECTED OFFICIAL IN
AMERICA, HOW DO YOU WANT TO BE
REMEMBERED?
THE CONSEQUENTIAL MOMENTS IN
HISTORY PRESENT A CHOICE.
DO YOU WANT TO BE ON THE SIDE OF
DR. KING, OR GEORGE WALLACE?
JOHN LEWIS OR BULL CONNOR?
DO YOU WANT TO BE ON THE SIDE OF
ABRAHAM LINCOLN OR JEFFERSON
DAVIS?
THIS IS THE MOMENT TO DECIDE.
>> Sean: THOSE REMARKS WERE SO
UNHINGED EVEN JO'S FELLOW
DEMOCRATS WERE PUT OFF,
DICK DURBIN SAID BIDEN WENT TOO
FAR.
NANCY PELOSI CRITICIZED HIM FOR
EVOKING BULL CONNOR AND STROM
THURMOND AND FORMER
CONGRESSWOMAN AND DEMOCRATIC
PRESIDENTIAL CANDIDATE
TULSI GABBARD TWEETED "HILLARY
CALLING TENS OF MILLIONS OF
AMERICANS DEPLORABLES WAS
DIVISIVE AND DISGUSTING, BIDEN
HAS GONE FURTHER CALLING THOSE
WHO DISAGREE WITH HIS ACTIONS
AND POLICIES DOMESTIC ENEMIES,
TRADERS, RACISTS AND BIDEN DID
PROMISE TO UNITE US BUT HE IS
DOING ALL HE CAN TO DIVIDE US.
TONIGHT IT APPEARS THE ONLY WAY
JOE BIDEN IS UNITING AMERICANS
IS AGAINST JOE BIDEN.
FORMER CONGRESSWOMAN
TULSI GABBARD JOINS US WITH
MORE.
GIVE YOUR OVERALL PERCEPTION OF
NOT ONLY THE SPEECH BUT THIS
WEEK AND THIS YEAR.
WE ARE A FEW DAYS AWAY FROM THE
ONE-YEAR ANNIVERSARY SINCE SINCE
HE WAS INAUGURATED.
>> I THINK THERE ARE SO MANY
PEOPLE ACROSS THE COUNTRY, THOSE
WHO VOTED FOR JOE BIDEN, THOSE
WHO DID NOT VOTE FOR JOE BIDEN
WHO HAD HIGH HOPES THAT HE WOULD
CARRY OUT HIS PROMISE, THAT HE
WOULD BE THE PRESIDENT FOR ALL
AMERICANS, SHOWING RESPECT FOR
THOSE WHO AGREED WITH HIM OR
DISAGREED WITH HIM.
UNFORTUNATELY THE OPPOSITE IS
TRUE.
NOT ONLY HAS HE NOT CARRIED OUT
ON THAT PROMISE, HE IS DOING THE
EXACT OPPOSITE, RAPIDLY CARRYING
OUR COUNTRY IN THE WRONG
DIRECTION, TEARING US APART,
POURING FUEL ON THE FLAMES OF
DIVISIVENESS AND IT REALLY MAKES
ME WONDER HOW WE CAN GO THROUGH
THREE MORE YEARS OF THIS AND
STILL COME OUT THE OTHER END
WITH THE POSSIBILITY OF BEING
ABLE TO COME TOGETHER AGAIN AS
AMERICANS AS THE UNITED STATES
OF AMERICA.
>> Sean: WHEN YOU LOOK AT FOR
EXAMPLE WE RAN OUT OF TESTS, WE
RAN OUT OF MONOCLONAL
ANTIBODIES, WE RAN OUT OF
ANTIVIRALS, INFLATION A 40 YEAR
HIGH, ENERGY $85 A BARREL, HE'S
BEGGING OPEC AND RUSSIA TO
PRODUCE MORE, HE INHERITED
ENERGY INDEPENDENCE, HIS VACCINE
MANDATE FELL APART.
THE AVERAGE AMERICAN MALL, THE
INFLATION OF EVERY AMERICAN
FAMILY IS ABOUT $5,000 PER
FAMILY.
IT IS IMPACTING EVERYBODY,
ALMOST ABOVE 50-GALLON PER GAS,
A THOUSAND MORE TO HEAT YOUR
HOME THIS YEAR, EVERYTHING WE
BUY IN EVERY STORE COST MORE,
THEIR SHELVES TRENDING, IT'S
EVERYWHERE.
DO YOU SEE AS A DEMOCRAT ANY OF
THESE POLICIES WORKING, AM I
MISSING SOMETHING THIS
SUCCESSFUL.
>> PEOPLE ARE STRUGGLING TO ME
CAN UNDERSTAND HOW PEOPLE ARE
FRUSTRATED AND ANGRY AND THE
FACT THAT OUR GOVERNMENT IS
FAILING US, ONE OF THE MOST
DISTURBING THINGS I SEE COMING
OUT OF THIS ADMINISTRATION IS
HOW PRESIDENT JOE BIDEN HAS HIS
ATTORNEY GENERAL TARGETING
AMERICANS AS DOMESTIC TERRORISTS
FOR BEING "ANTIAUTHORITY."
WHAT IS SO EXTREMELY DANGEROUS
ABOUT THIS IS THE PRESIDENT OF
THE UNITED STATES IS THE
AUTHORITY HERE IN AMERICA.
IF OUR PRESIDENT IS TARGETING
AMERICANS FOR BEING
"ANTIAUTHORITY" WHAT THEY ARE
REALLY SAYING IS YOU ARE AN
ENEMY OF THE STATE IF YOU ARE
AGAINST THE PRESIDENT OR HIS
POLICIES.
THIS IS THE FOUNDATION OF
AUTHORITARIANISM AND IT'S A
MESSAGE THAT IS RECEIVED BY
PEOPLE AT HOME.
IF YOU ARE GOING TO TARGET TO ME
FOR BEING AGAINST YOUR POLICIES
AS THE PRESIDENT, THERE WILL BE
CONSEQUENCES AND THEREFORE WHAT
OUR PEOPLE TO DO?
TO SHUT UP, STEP BACK AND FALL
IN LINE.
THIS IS UNACCEPTABLE IN OUR
DEMOCRACY AND MUST NOT GO
UNCHECKED.
>> HE HAS NEVER ALLOWED
REPUBLICANS IN THE ROOM,
REPUBLICANS WERE NEVER INCLUDED
IN BUILD BACK BETTER,
IN VOTER INTEGRITY MEASURES.
MY MEASURES I WOULD LIKE TO SEE
SO WE CAN HAVE CONFIDENCE IN
INTEGRITY WOULD BE SIMPLE.
VOTER I.D., SIGNATURE
VERIFICATION, CHAIN OF CUSTODY
CONTROLS SO WE MAKE SURE NOBODY
CAN TAMPER WITH MAIL IN BALLOTS,
I THINK WE NEED UPDATED VOTER
ROLLS AND I THINK WE NEED TO
PARTISAN OBSERVERS, ALL SIDES
GET TO WATCH THE VOTE COUNT UP
CLOSE START TO FINISH AND I
THINK WE WILL HAVE CONFIDENCE IN
RESULTS, I DON'T THINK ILLEGAL
IMMIGRANTS SHOULD BE ALLOWED TO
VOTE EITHER.
IS THERE ANYTHING WRONG WITH ANY
OF THOSE MEASURES IN YOUR VIEW
THAT I MENTIONED OR WOULD YOU
INCLUDE SOME OR TAKE SOME AWAY?
>> I THINK THE POINT THERE IS
THAT -- THE FACT THAT THERE WERE
NOT LEADERS, MEMBERS OF PARTIES
AND THE BOTH OF THEM CRAFTING
THIS LEGISLATION, THERE SHOULD
BE NO SURPRISE WHY THERE IS
PARTISAN OPPOSITION TO IT.
WHETHER OR NOT EVERYBODY WOULD
AGREE ON ALL OF THOSE THINGS ARE
EVEN -- I THINK THERE'S
OPPORTUNITY TO COME TO AGREEMENT
ON 80% OF THOSE THINGS AND STILL
BE ABLE TO MOVE US FORWARD AS A
COUNTRY.
THAT IS THE PROBLEM, THERE ARE
MANY DIFFERENT EXAMPLES
UNFORTUNATELY IN THIS
ADMINISTRATION WHEN THEY HAVE
CHOSEN TO TAKE A VERY PARTISAN
APPROACH AND EVEN THOUGH THEY
ARE LEAVING OUT REPUBLICANS ON
THE CRAFTING TABLE, THE
NEGOTIATING TABLE, THEN THEY SAY
HOW DARE YOU NOT SUPPORT OUR
BILLS THAT WE RODE WITHOUT ANY
OF YOUR INPUT OR ANY DISCUSSION,
ANY RESPECT OR CONSIDERATION,
THIS IS TRANSPARENT.
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE SEE WHAT'S
HAPPENING, I THINK AND ARE SO
DISSATISFIED BY IT.
>> Sean: WE ALWAYS LOVE HAVING